on this episode Indy and I get a ton and
I mean a ton of visitors
Oh
hi
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 191 of the ask Gary me
show it is loaded on the show today
uh-huh
a whole bunch of peeps joining us on a
very fun influencer entrepreneur show
one of the chapters in my book first
vaynernation thank you so much for
keeping me company on my 11 hour trip to
Sydney Australia Big Ups everybody down
in Sydney I had a lot of fun Cleveland
you guys to st. Louis Boston Atlanta
it's been a very busy week ladies and
gents India we missed you d-roc missed
you too when you figured out how to miss
your plane
that hurt Stefon great to see you Nick
good to see you man over there uh why
don't you guys first introduce
yourselves and then Indy and I will
start the show
while we start with the ladies awesome
my name is Sarah Deecee rhymes with
peachy I am a filmmaker photographer a
youtuber and professional internetter
and how did you get here because I think
it's a great story
um so basically I made a viral video
around a filmmaker and youtuber called
Casey nice dad yeah he featured me in
his vlog the next day after I made the
video and I knew I've been watching your
stuff for about a year and the first
person I emailed was Gary and the
subject line was a girl from Casey
Neistat video and so I was like let's do
this great glad quick-moving
awesome it's great to have you here so
what happened for everybody from the
story how many subscribers that you have
how much after the Casey show so I went
from four thousand subscribers to a
hundred thousand subscribers probably
today
yeah I'm right at ninety nine thousand
right now vaynernation
come on get up um see I'm sleepy yes in
two weeks good for you yeah yeah thank
you from originally from Dallas Texas
and I live in Nashville Tennessee yeah
all right I am Lauren Everett's I'm from
the skinny confidential it's a blog and
book and now a podcast and I'm really
excited to be here I've been a blogger
for five years awesome where do you live
San Diego and LA we kind of go both ways
my name is Michael Bostick I'm Lauren's
better half horse half now yours
um kind of the behind-the-scenes
business half of her vlog which is
crushing it how did it start
so I started while as the bartender I
was teaching pure bar I was broke as a
joke and I'm joking here it was how
bloke you are when you're joke India
really broke really broke started
blogging was a blogger for free for two
years just continue to create value and
content like you always say and just
love it it's my passion and I've been
doing it ever since
what was your kind of what was the thing
that kind of started like what do you
have a break via what was the first
moment that you got an interesting bump
um it's honestly there's no Epiphany
it's like such a slow build there's
nothing right well you don't say oh no
you had it I mean you had your mud yeah
I'm on my way
I had Conan when when I went on Conan o7
as a youtuber that was unheard of the
entire internet was like whoa like a
youtuber on television it was like a
crime it's so crazy I think to do
something like this you kind of just
like you said she loves it and flow
that's gonna slow she there's never been
like emotion doing was yours where do
you start the morning like the content
start living the contents on the blog
and that's my mothership and like the
blog in some I'm a big thing for you
instagrams big butt instagrams fleeting
and everything that's just started to
happen with it like I'm in my opinion
you're sad about the algorithm I'm not
sad cuz I'm in a snapshot so I don't
give that guy sky casts yeah oh no I
don't really give a [ __ ] about that I
mean I snapchat as where like I'm
focusing my attention so Instagram I'm
just kind of like whatever I mean I
still push that but it's not my like
favorite thing right and what else um
what else will we are doing a podcast
it's the skinny confidential him in her
podcast we're getting a male perspective
we're talking one-night stands with me
his perspectives really rude but his
perspective on one-night stands is it's
phenomenal oh you saw it
no but it's every dudes answer to that
question like that's a pretty universal
point of view so we're doing that I
don't you're down on that I'm fine I
want him to give advice to women instead
of men I feel like there's so many I say
you're giving advice to women I'm not
sure
that's funny I know I think I'm just
giving a male perspective on like so
she'll get to not insult some big
questions yes there's a lot of men
responding in an authentic way right the
bullshitting oh sure they're saying to
the Ferrari the Fonz always like no no I
hate it cuz he's trying to be a
gentleman but keep down when everybody
leaves
he tells d-roc you said I love it my
whole thing is like that yeah yeah yeah
I just think there's a lot of [ __ ]
guys on the internet right now and don't
know good news there's a lot of [ __ ]
guys period you're right [ __ ] but he
gives like a religion it's that guy's or
wired a certain way it's just chemicals
you can't be mad at him he's a hunter he
is a hunter but he needs to ring it in
and start giving advice to these girls a
Bundy hunters what do you think about
all this alright so the show so what do
we got we have three questions that in
you two we're gonna ask a question right
okay let's do it India Jonathan asks
would you say there is such a thing as a
viral formula to make things spread so
my point of view on this is that you
know 20 is a good time look Stefan I
know you'll be editing link-up the 60
years you know six minutes for 60 years
video in the opening line of that video
I say that the video is going to go
viral I don't think there's a formula
for going viral I really don't because
if there was then there would be more
people that could do it 40 50 100 times
I think there's concepts there's
concepts over here which is you goat or
bait or get the attention if somebody's
got a humongous audience you bring them
value in some way or do something unique
because everybody's doing that to case
'ty and she clearly did something that
was stronger better more interesting or
just a moment in time
d-roc was the thousandth person that
emailed me and said I want to make
videos for you at that moment I was
ready I was open for it it works so it's
a timing thing sometimes so there's
going after a bigwig to put you on what
dr. dre did for Snoop right it's a very
common thing in the rap game you give
somebody a verse it's a big song they're
big artists boom the game changes that
happens in influencer marketing there's
what I did with the six minutes or 60
years when I made that video I knew that
I was making it for 30 to 60 year-old
entrepreneurs so I targeted 30 to 60
year-olds on Facebook who were also into
shark tank and other
entrepreneurial things which gave it the
match to get it going so I think
Facebook ad targeting for video and I
think influencer marketing putting them
on our two formulas that work ladies
um I think going viral sometimes can
actually hurt you if you look at that
guy to leave Britney Britney Alone guy
he's known as that forever
personally I would prefer to grow slowly
organically authentically raw real and
really create content and maybe that
takes longer than going viral well let
me let me jump on this and I think
that's a tremendous point of view and
something that I push hard I will say
this I think that it comes down to how
good you are right so like if Beyonce
went viral at 16 off a video but she
actually had the chops like now we get
to find out what kind of shops she has
so I've seen people go viral and stay
because they're great they have staying
power
sure I watched you roam I watched really
I watched nicholas i watch the whole
vine movement and i was very close to
all Britney for a lot I watched all
their we picked Logan Paul to win a
contest that's how he gots career
started in a contest we created here in
vaynermedia so he went viral in that
moment but you gotta have the skills to
hold on to it right so I think look
tried-and-true like at the other day if
you don't have the chops if you don't
something say you're dead you're doing I
think it's important to have the backlog
of stuff so when you have that moment
people will stay for what you're
creating so it's like Gretchen you felt
that you felt a lot of people saying so
you have the moment and this is all very
recently women yeah so this is two weeks
ago right so people came and they got to
see all the stuff you did in the past
I'd like wait a minute you're good yeah
yeah my way I apologize to cut you up
like you yelled at for that I know I
know
uh I met you I don't know that Simon
actually attacks him and ask him I bet
you Casey probably even looked at that
to make his decision for it to even have
happened yeah yeah and so I think it's
super important to put yourself in a
position where it's like okay you have
the right context for maybe a viral
video but make sure like are you in a
point in your career or life to where
those people are gonna stay right um
didn't you sit didn't you have something
that someone told you about running a
multi-million dollar business that you
have to run a business like a
multi-million dollar business even if
you're not a multi-million I know I had
some advice a long time ago guys also
setting up a business and the guy said
what do I do like I have no idea
just get out of school he says set this
business up this is more to do with the
county goes set it up link it's a
multi-million dollar business so that
you're prepared for when it gets there
so do that spare you to do that like so
like do that with you think you're gonna
have a million viewers set it up to go
back it up so that when you get those
million viewers yeah they want to stand
elite wow this is legit like your
content you should be marketing like
you're marketing to ten million people
as long as as long as it's authentically
true to you I think the biggest mistake
that people make is fake the funk and
and I do it in a business context you
might have seen these characters back to
guys being jerk-offs like you have all
these guys that are faking the
entrepreneur life like they're winning
but it's not true to them and so when I
when I hear what you guys are saying
which is right advice I just want to
make sure everybody means that means as
long as it's true that means the
behavior not rolling like you did it or
acting like you're already famous yeah
exactly
India keep us moving nicole says
blogging since 2009 I know my target
audience I post regularly and promote on
all social numbers won't budge thoughts
my advice personally is be to keep at it
like it's something that I literally do
seven days a week there is not one day
that I've taken off in the last five
years you have to just crush it you have
to just see did you idiot
push back to the word skinny I mean
skinny is one of these new politically
incorrect words like three years ago and
it's it you've wondered that great so
I'm answer I'm answering the questions
are you know it's interesting you've
been doing this for a while I think it's
it's you're actually in a better place
where I don't think the words as
controversial but twenty four months ago
there was heat did you ever feel it all
the time but I like that I like heat on
me the things I talk about on my blog or
camel toes and boob jobs and vagina
steaming and enemas like I could go on
and on I talk about really controversial
taboo subjects that no one wants to deal
with so having the word skinny and the
titles really fitting for the brand
understand me when you're talking about
coconut Lube we're going to just go get
a tremendous thing for Lube though it
really which is a tremendous show on
this experiment everyone go home and try
it you will not be sorry that's your
birthday dear
ah I think that um I think that there is
one thing I do think that there's the
3-4 years and then you have your moment
I mean you look at it happens all the
time in real life Amy Schumer Amy
Schumer's career has been going on for a
decade
she's been like Kevin Hart Kevin Hart
was working at that [ __ ] 4/5 like 12/14
ito and you have your moment the problem
is one thing that I want people know is
it's not necessarily your numbers
growing it's how do you feel about it
currently my snapchat numbers are not
growing I've had my kind of 30,000 views
and I've been there for about a month I
feel fine with that because I feel like
I'm getting better at it I know what I
want to do next I know I've been
studying on doing other things because
the book has been coming out like I feel
content with myself even though that's
against the numbers too many people and
this is I'm sure
like something we all think about you're
gonna be think about it when you see the
podcast numbers as you start this new
venture this market is absolutely way
too deeply focused on numbers now Nick
and dumontet like they there's no
platform people buy on numbers I get it
you make your short-term money on
numbers you make your short-term that's
right you make your short-term money on
numbers so I would say who's the person
again yeah Nicole I would say if you
feel like you're moving the needle then
and you feel like you're getting closer
if you can taste it none of us can tell
you then you keep at it if you're
watching right now and you've been
trying to build your brand for 24 months
36 months you felt completely stagnant
both in the numbers both in the heat you
don't get recognized less selfies no
selfies no mention no friend even though
you're doing it if you feel stagnant I
actually compare this to wrestling so
stick with me I don't know if you know I
know you talk about coconut oil but I'm
gonna talk ability WUF wrestling for a
minute when when you look at gimmicks
right gimmicks is like when you're mr.
perfect or the Red Rooster or what have
you there's a lot of wrestlers who have
three or four gimmicks and then they
become Stone Cold Steve Austin and
they've been for other things and it
didn't take but the new thing works now
the difference there is that's a
character I could have stopped doing the
wine thing and started a Jets thing and
I could be on ESPN right now whatever
and then I did a business thing
I had three things that I could have
probably done as me wine business and
the Jets now I've done two I may become
a Jets a sports writer if you have other
interests if you're doing a blog about
root beer or about skateboarding but
you're also into clothes or Jam or
rollerblading if you feel very stagnant
for two or three years your system and
your thing might be right but your topic
may be wrong to you it may not be that
moment in time so that's another version
to think about this if you feel in your
heart and numbers a 24 36 months tagging
because I do see people I mean I know
people right now because I've been doing
this since oh six who've been doing the
same thing for seven eight years and
there's nothing that's gonna you always
talk about talent it's real yeah it's
real industry and interaction I think in
it it is real that you have to have
talent if you don't have talent in this
industry I think you are going to get
washed away so you have to know who you
are like you said like you have to
remain authentic to yourself and if you
think you have talent to be a blogger
then blog every day how long were you
doing YouTube before this I started
YouTube in like 2012 and then I was
consistent this past August and so I
think you what maybe what happened in
August that made you get really going
III was I was like I want to build a
business someday and I know having an
audience is valuable and so I just
started with travel vlogs I started I
love filmmaking I love making videos yep
and so it wasn't hard for me because I
love doing it and I also think that
interaction with people is so important
you can look at the numbers all day but
who who is like mentioning you on
Twitter who is retweeting things who is
favoriting things and makes Twitter an
important platform for you yes it has
been so interactive I only have about
5,000 followers but everyone is so
interactive and every it's a awesome way
to do you interact with your YouTube
comments yes okay so glad you asked that
question because when I had 3000
followers I made it a habit to comment
to every single comment every single
comment it's hard to do it now it's so
crazy to watch you guys spur up from all
the theses that I wrote seven eight
years ago it's so crazy I know I read
you crush it like recently and I was
like holy [ __ ] he predicted the future
it is weird it is we're telling you I
read that influencer chapter in your new
book and it's like it's it's refreshing
to have somebody with such a loud voice
say it
it's what we have been thinking and
working on and saying for five six years
now
sure tell them about what happened
recently it to me on a shoot because
you'll this kind of goes into like
influencer marketing as well we banned
recently brought her on to offer her
voice and get perspective and it was a
video thing of four videos 30 seconds
yeah they brought her in and they said
hey you're gonna stick to this script
you're gonna do this thing it had 15
people on set they completely got away
from her poison was kind of like what's
the point why do you want me when I got
it I got fired up about it cuz I said
this brand's on its way out no it's not
it's been yeah and it fired up for her
because her brand's I know I don't know
what happened did you do it I know I did
it I did the script I did what they said
but the point is is they could have
hired a model or an actress to just read
it they don't need a blogger I'll never
do it again her voice and trying to get
her audience and they're not gonna use
my voice they have 15 people on there we
produce six of those videos in three
hours but three of us
they micromanage everything I think
brands need to let the influencer do
what they do look what was dailyvee like
it's literally d-roc and garyvee like
and it works you know it you don't have
five people following you around the
curated things out I think it's on its
way so out so Don it's well the bigger
issue is that the people that follow you
know that's not you exactly and that's
and that's why there's no that's right
and there's no money they can pay you
that makes it worth it for you yeah I
mean I had early deals for Wine Library
TV before this was a real thing and a
car company wanted me to drive a car
into Wine Library and it was so wild
there was so early days and I was like
it was a lot of money at the time and I
didn't do it because even then back in
oh seven oh eight I was just like I just
it just I think I'm gonna think people
gonna be like forget it like Gary sold
out that was so scary
I don't it's so different out Fran I
don't it's a little bit more accepted
now but we refused to sell ad space on
the side you're the center's no now I'll
forget by the way if I grow up during
this time I would have done it like back
then it was just so there was just not
there was there was not a single video
on YouTube that had a million views when
I started like it was just a bit like I
mean this was 2006 how old were you in
2006 I was in sixth grade yeah so like
you know to me like it was a different
world India keep us moving is it hi Gary
I'm Piper Reese from Piper's
Stevi and I'm here at the 2016
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards orange
carpet so I've done over 700 interviews
since I was 7 years old and I've also
been pitching a scripted TV show concept
eventually I want to expand to an online
TV network sort of thing so I want your
advice on how to monetize where do I go
from here and Lincoln anivia oh that is
so Piper I'll I'll save you a ton of
time let's do it ASAP tell me where
you're at get to New York call me um
actually sorry Piper actually um that
was amazing what do you guys think about
that um I think that when she talks
about how to monetize I think a lot the
short game is to go for brands the
long-term game would to be continued her
hosting on YouTube push it on her
platforms and maybe even grow it into
like sort of a brand where she has a
clothing line I mean she's adorable
she has red hair which is different she
could do something with that so I think
their own little Network and honestly
yeah and yeah and I also think right now
you know it's not about the ads the
pre-roll ads it's about what are brands
like who are the brands that want to
work with you and that makes sense with
your brand you know if you spot you know
have hoverboards sponsor a video no
one's going to care but if you if you
really possible yeah yeah so you know
find things that work with your brand
and integrate it into your content don't
you know whatever I think I will
definitely have you on the show you'll
interview me and during that show I'll
give you much more detailed answers
because it's really predicating your
situation I don't know the financial
situation of your parents or your
situation there's so many things like I
hate giving general advice when there's
an opportunity of specific advice so
since we're going to be hanging out I'll
go there I think the longer you can wait
the more you will make if you've got the
talent and so I think that's the real
key I think the other thing is you know
I notice all the things you had there if
I were you I would aggressively start
looking at musically I don't know what
you guys are doing with musically if
either one of you are on it but I think
that is the absolute platform of junior
high right now and it seems like that
would be a very smart place for you to
go so I would continue to be first mover
in new places because I think you're at
such a young age where that could be a
big big big advantage supply and demand
is differently I'm musically
on snapchat Instagram or YouTube so
we'll have specific advice for you Piper
very soon that was cool
all right now you guys what do you got
okay I was thinking of questions and I
pretty much know all the answers that
you would yeah say so yeah I've been
watching your stuff for a year so a lot
of I'll give you a question a lot of
people had was if they're trying to
start a YouTube channel
yes in your opinion how do you break
through all these stuff that is on there
right now I mean we've talked about it
you know the answer talent is the
variable I really do think
self-awareness that's why I put on the
cover of this book is super important
you know I spent a lot of time like
there was three things I could have
started with and I went with wine
because I knew that I wasn't gonna be
able to leave the wine business right
away I had a business to run and so it
was the most kind of like integrated
thing that I could do so you've got to
think about your subject matter it has
to be true to you all of us have
multiple things that are true to us so I
would sit down and first say what do I
actually know I know how to be a
thirteen year old I know the thirteen
year olds point of view on technology
then I would go to YouTube and I would
see how many people are winning the
eleven to fifteen year old technology
point of view content game if there's
nobody I would say and there's almost
nobody there's somebody for everything
almost but if there's not that many
people or nobody really owning it that's
interesting
versus I also a great skateboarder oh
crap there's ninety seven thousand
people doing skateboarding so first and
foremost I would look for the white
space number two I do think that
YouTube's a very difficult game and I do
think that whether it's snapchat though
that's about to become very difficult as
well I'm going to say it again musically
or anything else that pops I think using
other social networks white space to
drive awareness and attention matters
and then finally I mean we gave this
question early on I do think the
blueprint of what you did with Casey or
if you've got a couple of bucks and you
can run ads against you know people that
are skateboard fans on Facebook there is
tactical things that can speed up your
process
I do think influencers are the way to go
I think Piper recalling it all the way
back should absolutely spend all her if
she loves it spend all her time going to
every Instagram account every youtuber
every Twitter account and replying to
people and saying can I interview you
can I promise
probably what she's doing if she's
interviewed so many people and the truth
is one more ask is one more at-bat so I
would see that and something to that all
the things that I've 70 percent of the
stuff that I've done on my youtube
channel is about other people and so
like series like creative space TV or
anything it's all about going to other
people you're siphoning people's
audience and I'm leveraging others
people a hundred percent for me and it's
I've learned it by the way and I haven't
looked enough but I'm gonna make some
assumptions here everybody does that
it's you have to be good at it
like you what you clearly have done is
you brought valued you know when I put
stuff out I rarely do it it's because
somebody sings a book review of mine and
then kills it you know like like it's
somebody that has to bring value like if
you've got a big audience everybody's
trying to get to you everybody's trying
to siphon your fans and you know
linkbait you it's can you bring value to
that community and to that person you
know it's funny that's how she started
she started interviewing models
Instagram horse my whole platform has
been not competing collaborating yeah of
course when you're starting from the
bottom you absolutely
either need money you need an absolute
unbelievable skill set of talent or you
need to siphon awareness from other
places but too many people want too many
people like hit up people like hey you
have a million followers on Twitter can
you give me a shout out know what kind
of value are you offering that a hundred
percent and really not even like
structuring like and not the email that
says what can I do for you for you to do
this for me it's just doing it and that
like you didn't you didn't text Casey
and say hey I'm going to do this for you
like you did it yeah and you know I had
4,000 people who really cared about me
because I had built that relationship
with my YouTube audience for years and
so when at the end of the videos like
alright guys I'll Street us - Casey
let's get it to him you know people are
stoked about it
chase Norman the Nickelodeon star did
the same thing to me like all of a
sudden God on a plane has like seven
thousand tweets from the Norman maniacs
run okay my question is when did you
decide to build and why your personal
brand instead of focusing on other
people's brands so like how did you
decide to just put all your eggs in this
basket as opposed to kind of putting
your eggs in a bunch of different basket
for me it's because I'm actually a
business operator like I built a big
wine retail and e-commerce business
before I became garyvee I mean don't
forget very different than you guys and
most of people's tracks now I was 30
years old and had built a business
before I ever made my first video I
didn't grow up in this generation if I
did I probably would have I probably
wouldn't be laughing right now and
showing videos of baseball-card kid Gary
you know it's like a 15 year old saying
by the Frank Thomas rookie card like
like I just didn't grow up in that era
and so for me I'm the reason I could
build vaynermedia and the reason I don't
you know just live off of being me like
I always say like I'm the CEO of
vaynermedia I run businesses I'm a
venture capitalist who plays Gary Vee at
times I like this I like this like I
think it's important it brings
opportunity but it's a it's at the end
of the day in my purest form I'm a
business man much more than I am a
personality and so what vaynermedia did
for me was it scales my marketing skill
set to deploy against people or brands
or my own brands I want to buy brands in
the future so that's kind of my play on
that uh yeah I think I think for
everybody you need to really think about
how you want to monetize this are you
gonna deploy it against a product like I
had a deal from Target and CIA to do a
wine glass that I probably would have
been millions of dollars on it would've
been in every Target store would've been
the big wine glass it would have been
the product the season it didn't feel
like I didn't feel like I could Vig the
outcome and let me break this down this
gonna be the most valuable part of
things
the place where you want to make your
money is the place where you think you
have the most control not where you can
make the most money it's great and it's
something that I haven't really talked
about so I'm glad I feel like we got to
something we kind of forgot some long
hide this can you like elaborate on
comic books are an interesting place
that I plan it's one of the places i
monetize because I can control it I sell
the books not HarperCollins not Amazon
not Barnes and Nobles me I can dictate
it doing a sponsorship deal with a wine
glass like at that point I wasn't big
enough to feel that I was gonna drive
thousands if not tens of thousands of
people into target to buy it maybe a
thousand maybe 3,000 but not enough for
target to care if that was the only
people that bought it so
you want to do is always set yourself up
in a place where the outcome is
impressive to whoever you collaborate
with or the market right so like if you
can sell your own music
direct-to-consumer digitally and you get
a million downloads and you did it well
now you have leverage and so it's all
everything's about leverage and what
happens is too many people take the
short term money and they what happens
is then there's a result there's too
many for example I and I won't call them
out because it's I don't like negativity
but there's 12 to 15 social media
experts who get paid to speak and get
paid to consult whose books so to 3,000
copies if you're so good at social media
marketing then would understand wouldn't
have you done that to sell your book and
so these conversations are happening
behind the scenes not publicly I will
throw them out like other people but
there's people not hiring them or they
have them as a c-class citizen because
they're like well look at their books
can numbers like I showed them are a
hundred thousand copies of my book the
first week Wow and that's a very big
difference from people and by the way if
I list some of the names of the people
that I'm referring to it for a lot of
people that follow social media other oh
yeah Gary's kind of like that guy or
that girl's kind of like Gary no or not
like they didn't build a hundred million
dollar business they didn't sell 100
that like and so for me I have the
audacity in bravados because what I
preach is also what I use to create
results you guys look you guys are
living it and you think I'm doing the
right stuff and I'm an old dude right
like I'm doing snapchat right I'm doing
a blog but the way tells us like our
ships in the right direction because I
mean there's a lot of people when we
first started like what are you doing
yeah why are you taking these pictures
like it is cool that you're that you're
this age and you know how to do social
me listen to tell you I'm almost dead
and you know like um but aren't you the
only social media expert that's ever
been on the New York Times bestseller no
I'm sure I'm sure there's others um and
I don't really even like know what like
where the line is of like social media X
or what have you but look I have real
results like this book is we just found
all thank you that's a good segue but
the guys thank you so much just found
out yesterday it's coming out a week or
two you know askgaryvee made the New
York Times best selling less so that's
like four books that have done it but
way more thank you that's it like a
weird like list where a lot of things
are weighted it's how many I sold right
like I had a great calm
with my editor yesterday I'm a free
agent now and I can go to any publisher
what-have-you and I'm like look I'm like
I didn't get number one which is what we
wanted right I think it's number six on
the list I said ah she's like oh this is
[ __ ] she was like mad she wanted to
be higher because it's an algorithm not
just copy sold
I said don't cry for me I'm like you're
not giving me my next deal based on if I
was number one or number six you're
going to be the next deal based on how
many were sold right you made three
million dollars in revenue like like
like that you know like that's what so I
think um you have to know what your
North Star is all right any question you
like this is a bunch of marketing people
business people entrepreneurs this would
be a smart time to ask question that you
might get value from from Facebook and
YouTube you go first
okay okay where do you guys see snapchat
in the next two to three years
great question do you guys think Twitter
is dead cuz I'm really liking it still
really good questions guys thank you for
being on the show my man Brian thank you
for thank you for educating the women of
America thank you wanna go girl
one more thing I'm giving out three
askgaryvee books to find me on twitter
retweet my pinchley
I'm giving out three on stop chat I'm
gonna go for keep asking questions we
will keep answering it